en su primera semana en el cargo yo
vaivén ya está mostrando su compromiso
con una de sus prioridades el medio
ambiente el miércoles el presidente
firmó tres órdenes ejecutivas con el
objetivo de revertir las políticas de
trump escéptico ante el cambio climático
en mi opinión ya hemos esperado mucho
tiempo para lidiar con la crisis
climática y ya no podemos esperar más
sentimos eso y sabemos que es tiempo de
actuar bones instaura la primera orden
pretende acabar con los permisos para la
extracción de gas y petróleo en
territorios federales con esta medida va
a ir en cumpliría una de sus promesas
electorales con el fin de conseguir la
neutralidad de carbono en el sector de
la energía para el 2035 bajo el mismo
paraguas la administración de biden
busca mantener la integridad del 30 por
ciento de los territorios y aguas
federales cuando de detener la pérdida
de biodiversidad de las órdenes también
se incluye la creación de un nuevo
consejo científico que asesorará a
bailén en cuestiones relativas al cambio
climático por último el presidente insta
a cambiar toda la flota de vehículos
oficiales que pasarán a ser eléctricos
esta orden ejecutiva ayudará a reforzar
este compromiso trabajando con otras
naciones para ayudar a las más
vulnerables a afrontar el cambio
climático además de fomentar la
resistencia colectiva julien's
bailén además anunció una cumbre sobre
el cambio climático con líderes
mundiales fijada para el 22 de abril la
cita coincide con el quinto aniversario
del acuerdo de parís al que eeuu volvió
poco después de que bardem jugase como
presidente